[Music]
delocated a very funny show uh i'm
driving down sunset boulevard uh and i
see this massive billboard for the show
uh and i like really pushing the blues
boulevard
and i see him as a billboard uh
and uh it's for delocated check out this
billboard there it is
and it's got a um
uh i guess that's you your character
that's my character who always wears a
ski mask on the show yeah he's in the
witness protection program and they've
done this billboard campaign the last
few seasons of it's kind of like calvin
klein underwear campaign it's me and the
ski mask and my underwear right and it's
usually been a big huge image which have
all been great and this one they had the
idea for a little guy on top as if he's
sitting up there yeah and the cut out i
think we have a photo of the cutout you
have the actual cutout there is the
actual cutout
wow it's actually uh it's quite large
that cutting yeah it's a little bigger
than life size so on the billboard it's
a little bit readable yeah i like to
call the area if you can bring that up
just one more time yeah the area right
between my my uh my tits and my tummy as
i like to say i like to call that the
blast zone all right i don't know
filled with solid tnt tits
[Music]
[Applause]
horrible horrible man uh
now
we have a clip here heading to the blast
oh my god
we got a is that guy in the photo a
demolitions expert yeah yeah andy don't
encourage all right i'm sorry
i like it we have a clip here from
delocated now uh of course the concept
being that you were in the witness uh
relocation program the winners program
so
and your voice is altered in addition to
the ski mask yeah it's modulated very
much like when someone's on the news and
they pitch them down that kind of low
garbled voice yeah that's my character's
permanent voice yes he has that voice
all the time it's a very funny idea for
a show and i think we have a clip here
what do we need to know for this clip in
this clip uh my character has moved into
a sweet loft that he's very excited
about and he bought himself a potato
skins bar that he's very excited about
he's got it all set up to have a
housewarming party to meet his new
neighbors let's take a look at this clip
from delocated
[Music]
[Music]
how psyched are the neighbors gonna be
for this housewarming party especially
for that six-foot party skin all right
tb
how many skins you think i can fit in my
mouth
i don't know three nope four
get it four skins
no i get it yeah yeah i get it
first
[Applause]
[Music]
horrified i am horrified by you